the secret is out now that all six
episodes of Marvel secret Invasion are
out on Disney plus repercussions from
this scroll Showdown are sure to Ripple
throughout the MCU warning spoilers for
secret Invasion ahead
secret invasion moves quickly taking
place over the span of a few weeks the
series includes numerous flashbacks to
depict unseen parts of Nick Fury's life
and explain how he lost the trust and
respect of the Scrolls after failing to
find them a home now three decades after
Captain Marvel there are now more than a
million Scrolls on Earth most are hidden
and living peacefully however many also
defected to gravic's terrorist regime
including talos's daughter Gaia before
she started feeding her father
information and ultimately defected back
to his side the dark tone of the series
is clear immediately when gravic
disguised as Fury kills an unsuspecting
Maria Hill at the end of episode 1.
another loss comes in episode 4 when
graphic does the same thing to Talos
during his attack on president ritzen in
England in the attack gravic who has
made himself into a super scroll and his
soldiers are masquerading as the
Russians to set the scene for a World
War this is just part of his plan though
graphic hopes to force Fury into giving
him Avengers DNA too Fury explains at
the end of the fifth episode
if I don't give graphic the Harvest then
Roadie is going to incinerate
the scroll compound if that happens
Russia will counter and War will begin
the stakes couldn't be any higher when
episode 6 of secret Invasion begins
president ritzen is poised to declare
war on the Russians thanks to his
adviser Rhody who is really the scroll
rava Gaia Fury and MI6 agent Sonya
fallsworth worked to stop the Scrolls in
the Giza Fury Gaia faces graphic while
Sonia helps the real Fury trap the
Imposter Roadie gravity confuses the
Avenger DNA into his body not expecting
it to also work on Gaia whom he believes
is about to die from radiation poisoning
however Gaia absorbs the new powers too
and reveals herself to graphic
ultimately killing him with a beam of
energy just before that as Fury Gaia
tells gravic
I should have taught you
never give up the fight this line marks
the turn of the tide afterward Gaia goes
to free the human prisoners from the
scroll compound including the real
Colonel Rhodes upon learning that he's
been counseled by a scroll ritzen aborts
the attack on Russia and prevents a
global crisis Fury makes plans to head
off world and find the Scrolls a home
for real this time back in the UK Sonja
becomes the head of the British secret
intelligence service
after they helped reunite Talos and his
family and Captain Marvel Nick Fury and
Carol Danvers promised to help find the
Scrolls a new planet to call home
neither of them did that but Fury
continued to use the Scrolls to help him
Advance his career
Samuel L Jackson who plays Fury told
Vanity Fair Nick had a whole scroll spy
Network because they could shape-shift
and go places the people couldn't go
they kept their word they worked for him
but he hasn't done what he said he was
going to do they want a home they want
to live they want to live like they are
they want to live in their skin they
don't want to live in ours Graphics
faction of squirrel extremists was born
out of Fury neglecting his promise and
this is part of what makes Graphics such
a compelling villain so why didn't Fury
find them a home and prevent this from
happening the answer is finally revealed
in episode 6 when Gaia as Fury explains
that the real Fury searched for years
but didn't find a Planet suitable for
them ultimately she says Fury failed to
change the hearts and minds of the
people of Earth into accepting the
Scrolls though it's not clear whether
this is what the real Fury thinks
throughout the series gravic is looking
for something of theories to help him
become the perfect super scroll it seems
that he has done so when he regenerates
after Fury shoots him in the cheek Gaia
reveals this is the result of the DNA
samples he got from call obsidian and
adopted child of Thanos and a flora
Colossus which is Groot species but
graphic knows there's something more
powerful out there the Harvest when Gaia
tells Fury that's what he's after it's
obvious by Fury's reaction that the
situation has escalated
in episode 5 Fury explains to Sonya that
almost every avenger shed blood during
the climax of Avengers end game and he
sent gravics team to collect the DNA
samples after the battle of Earth the
DNA was combined to create the Harvest
essentially a new super soldier serum
that can recreate the powers of some of
Earth's mightiest heroes and villains
it's what gives gravic and Gaia the
abilities they use to fight each other
during their final battle
the most important component of the
Harvest is Carol Danvers DNA at least
according to graphic who's gone to
extreme lengths to get it when he puts
himself through the machine to imbue
himself with the power in the Harvest he
unintentionally gives the same powers to
Gaia whom he believes to be a radiation
poisoned Nick Fury gravic finally claims
his opportunity to kill Gaia but she
blocks his punch the pair tests out
their new powers in a fight to the death
featured most prominently are Hulk and
Korg strength the ice of frost Beast
mantis's psychic empathy and Captain
Marvel's Powers gravic has the power to
regenerate but nothing can save him from
a Captain Marvel level energy beam which
leaves a gaping hole in his chest not
only does this further prove that
Captain Marvel is one of the most
powerful Avengers around it's also
appropriate given that Captain Marvel is
the film in which the Scrolls debuted in
the MCU
plenty of fans wondered throughout
secret Invasion why Nick Fury never
called in any Avengers to help given the
status quo of the MCU as of the end of
phase four Fury has two hulks he could
have contacted plus a new black panther
two Hawkeyes Thor Ant-Man the WASP
stature Dr Strange Wong the new Captain
America and of course the often absent
Captain Marvel they'd probably want to
know that their friend Rhodey had been
kidnapped by skrulls after all there's
also Ms Marvel but maybe Fury doesn't
know about her yet and everybody forgot
about Spider-Man
Fury never makes that call for the
simple reason that this is a very
personal fight for him not only is he
haunted by his failed promise but he's
also fighting to save his wife Priscilla
and honor Taylor's sacrifice he explains
to Sonia that only he can defend the
world this way we can't keep depending
on these superheroes to swoop in and
save our asses
none of them have lived the life I have
after discovering that he was being
manipulated by rava who's been posing as
Roadie president ritzen stops the U.S
attack on Russia before it's two lanes
he knows how close the world came to an
all-out war and holds the Scrolls
responsible not just the ones from
Graphics extremist faction all of them
Ritz and threatens their lives on a
public broadcast detailing his plan to
go before the Senate to present an
emergency Bill declaring all aliens
enemy combatants Fury tells ritzen that
he's overreacting and blaming the many
for the actions of the few Fury tells
the president a bad situation and made
it worse that's real one-term president
stuff this is actually an indicator of
what's to come as anyone who has been
keeping up with upcoming Marvel releases
will know Captain America Brave New
World is due in 2024. joining Anthony
Mackey and Sebastian Stan is Harrison
Ford making his MCU debut as president
Thunderbolt Ross so it looks like
ritzen's Administration will indeed only
be in the white house for just one term
foreign
after killing gravic in episode 6 and
the death of her father Talos in episode
4 Gaia becomes the de facto new leader
of the Scrolls in the final moments of
the series she is confronted by Sonia
fallsworth the newly appointed head of
the sis who offers her a deal unlimited
resources in exchange for help I will
use you you will use me
and together we'll make this planet safe
for both our people
intrigued by the offer Gaia goes with
her but there is an important difference
between this Arrangement and the deal
Fury and Talos made all those years ago
Gaia and Sonia are business partners
there is nothing personal at stake
between the two of them with this Clean
Slate Gaia might finally be able to
achieve what Talos couldn't perhaps she
can find a safe home for all her people
where they can truly be themselves and
she can establish a lasting peace
between the Scrolls and the humans
however this will not be an easy task at
the end of the episode Sonia discovers a
room filled with pods it's at that point
that she realizes the true strength of
her foe this is how the enemy got so
good it's not entirely clear what she
means by the statement however if the
Scrolls have taken control of hundreds
of high-ranking humans Gaia definitely
has a long road ahead
from early on in secret Invasion it's
clear something is wrong with Colonel
Rhodes he's Sterner than usual and
abruptly fires Nick in the wake of Maria
Hill's death this isn't the war machine
we know so when it's revealed that he's
been replaced by the scroll rava
everything starts to make sense however
it's not clear how long Roadie was held
captive some fans have speculated that
his capture took place at some point
after the events of the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier but has it been longer
when she saves him Gaia tries to explain
to Rody that he'd been held captive for
a very long time and Marvel boss Kevin
feige outright said to the independent
that we've seen rava impersonating Rhody
in previous Marvel projects when he's
rescued Rhodes is wearing a hospital
gown this implies that he could have
been replaced after the events of
Captain America Civil War while he was
in recovery from the injuries he
suffered in that movie if that's true
the Roadie we knew has missed out on
some major events in the MCU thankfully
he's free now but we can expect to see
some pretty big changes for Roadie going
forward if rava was impersonating him
when he took the job with the president
will the real Roadie continue on in that
role we certainly imagine he's going to
have something to say about this ordeal
in his upcoming feature armor Wars
despite the Rebellion boiling underneath
the Surface fomented by the scroll
gravic and losing his access to his
government resources Fury still manages
to help save the world so it's no
surprise that at the end of the series
we see him get back to work he was never
going to go quietly into retirement this
was alluded to in episode 5 when Fury
puts his eye patch back on Samuel L
Jackson said Fury not wearing it at the
beginning was an indicator of his
character's Journey speaking with Vanity
Fair he said he just doesn't wear the
patch the patch is part of who the
strong Nick Fury was it's part of his
vulnerability now you can look at it and
see he's not this perfectly
indestructible person he doesn't feel
like that guy
at the end of the series Fury has a
renewed sense of self and Duty he's
headed out on a mission to right his
wrong and do what he should have done
all along find a home for the Scrolls
saber is backing the mission to broker
peace with the cree and fury is at the
Forefront of that effort
one of the biggest surprises in secret
Invasion comes in episode 2 when it's
revealed Nick Fury has been married for
decades Fury married Priscilla who was
actually a scroll named Vara after the
events of Captain Marvel though it seems
they were happy for a while as evidenced
by their honeymoon in Finland as the
show begins they are completely
estranged from each other secret
Invasion reveals several series of
twists and turns about Priscilla and
Fury's relationship including that
Priscilla is involved with gravic's
Rebellion but when the time comes she
defies orders to kill Fury the price she
pays is that she has to put her life on
the line instead the odds are stacked
against Fury and Vara given that they
literally come from different worlds but
despite their past and the current
conflict they are still lovers looking
to find each other again after suffering
through great trauma
by the end they both have taken a few
steps toward each other most important
for their reunion varro reveals her true
self to Fury before he leaves for his
new Mission when he sees her as a scroll
for the first time he promises to love
her for who she really is this marks a
fresh start for the couple and fury asks
Farah to come on the mission with him
and help negotiate the peace talks with
the cree
while secret Invasion provides a
compelling conclusion to the threat of
gravic's terrorist skrels it leaves
plenty of unanswered questions in room
for story lines to continue down the
line this might happen sooner than
expected since the Marvels which
premieres in November 2023 is a sequel
to five MCU projects Captain Marvel
Wanda Vision Avengers end game Miss
Marvel and secret Invasion since the
movie takes place after the series Nick
Fury and vara's peace talks with the
cree will have begun or potentially been
completed Gaia might be one of the
Scrolls set to appear in the Marvels as
well since she's not just their leader
but also one of the most powerful
characters in the MCU now it's possible
she'll have a Target on her back across
the Galaxy with anyone seeking to use
her blood to recreate the Harvest serum
for themselves Roadie's storyline from
Secret Invasion will also continue but
in armor Wars rather than the Marvels
foreign